so the Republicans are heading to Tampa
to whoop it up at their yes we did to
build it ourselves convention Florida
and late August goodness gracious
it's not about the heat or the humidity
about the nudity there's a reason that
Tampa was chosen as the backdrop for
Magic Mike the hard-bodied hit movie of
the summer the city is packed ass cheek
to jowl with strip clubs catering to
every customer niche that's capitalism
at its finest baby and something that
GOP pretends to understand the moist
evening air in the lightening capital of
America ripples with anticipation the
way the chins of convention speakers
like Chris Christie do at snack time is
it just a coincidence that Mitt Romney
picked Congressman Paul Ryan to be his
running mate hardly pull-ups push-ups
sit-ups lots of cardio karate jump
training yoga brian is a highly public
practitioner of the p90x insanity
workout I keep my body fat between six
and eight percent brian famously wear
two suits David Byrne style two sizes
too big but as anyone who saw Magic Mike
can tell you oversized clothes just make
the stripper reveal that much sexier
your local strip club owners aren't
expecting the GOP base to flood the red
light zones one of them told the press I
don't think these people are coming to
party yeah whatever
maybe the top and the bottom of the GOP
ticket ought to skip the boring speech
as we funny hats at the convention
center and instead check out the flesh
at Pampa in fact MIT Romney could get to
know the non-unionized independent
contractors who worked so hard for their
money and have overcome more than a few
bumps and grinds to inject life into an
economy that is limper than Liberace at
a speculum convention strippers like the
rest of us built their business the
old-fashioned way they earned it and the
loosened up GOP that showed some kinship
or should I say skinship with real
hard-working men and women just might be
worth tip in a few bucks for recent TV
and Kennedy